[Applause]
thank you
booster after chamber pressures
vehicle Tower cleaner to win the picks
over the pulsory reports first stage
engines model what a cycling carrots
or flying at twice the thrust of the
Standard Time
Christy
we're throttled down and throttled back
up
going through the period of Maximum
aerodynamic pressure
[Applause]
foreign
continuing to watch the first stage as
we head downrange
[Music]
100 seconds into flight
our next major activity
on the first stage the Houston tracking
station now acquiring the vehicle
[Applause]
separates we light up six engines in a
staggered sequence if all goes well
those six engines will burn for almost
six and a half minutes onboard view from
Star
s and their views of the Raptor engines
on the second stage as we prepare for
stage separation now after safe
separation the first stage will flip and
begin a boost back maneuver for landing
in the Gulf
[Music]
thank you
continuing to fly two minutes 40 seconds
let's get ready for main engine cutoff
[Music]
as of right now we are awaiting stage
separation
where Starship should separate from the
super heavy booster
yeah Kate right now it looks like we saw
the start of the flip but obviously
we're seeing from the ground cameras the
entire Starship stack continuing to
rotate we should have had Separation by
now obviously this is uh does not appear
to be a nominal situation yeah it does
appear to be spinning but I do want to
remind everyone that everything after
clearing the tower was icing on the cake
and there as you saw as we promised an
exciting end to the Starship inaugural
integrated test flight
[Applause]